we have been dealing with functions for
quite some time yeah right and what
we're going to do now is think about how
how do functions interact with each
other particularly in the context of
graphs now the point of us introducing
this particular idea addition and
subtraction of functions the point of us
tooi this is so that number one all the
functions you've ever looked at in the
past that in any way involved addition
and subtraction we will understand them
better it's like a new lens to look at
an old object you're like oh cool there
are things I didn't see before right and
secondly there are some functions which
we will not know how to graph with the
regular old methods that we've got right
there's no like contradict formula
there's no like oh just put this number
you get the y-intercept we will need to
rely on this new method to graph these
future functions that we haven't looked
at yet okay now just to quickly
illustrate what I mean by a new lens to
look at an old object do you remember we
introduced the idea of oddity even
functions right you have that like some
functions many functions in fact have
different kinds of symmetry right now
one of the examples that we gave you for
a function which has even symmetries x
squared yeah now you've been dealing
with x squared for a long like four
years at this point right but you're
never new to call it an even function
you never knew to call y equals x you
never knew to call that an odd function
but now we give you this new way to
think of it right the reason it's useful
morning is because now if we think about
things with audit even powers right
which is where the audit even names come
from right for example if I gave you a
function like X cubed minus X right so
this guy here right this has what kind
of symmetry
have a peek I'm already telling you a
symmetry you can see it
this is rotational symmetry right which
is odd symmetry there way I knew that
this would give me an odd function I
didn't know what it's gonna look like
but the reason are you is just have a
look at what this graph is it's actually
let me write it properly it's actually X
cubed take away X to the 1 do you see
that so all my powers are odd do you
know that they're all odd numbers and so
whatever I'm going to get out is gonna
be odd
I don't know exactly what it's going to
look like but if I add on say X to the
power of pick another odd number for me
I've got lots of odd numbers let's go
with 7 ok sure now this one here right
actually let's just make it a little
more interesting listed there we go okay
let's uh maybe affirmative oh yeah there
we go what what what is going on there
right now it yeah it does kind of
doesn't it right so this shape here I
didn't know what was going to come out
when I started to press the numbers but
I knew it was going to have odd symmetry
because I've got all these odd powers
here does that make sense right so this
is like oh it starts with simple objects
like this right you're like oh okay do
we need to know what even symmetry is to
describe this object it's just no we
don't we already know what this is about
but what happens is once you know what
on an even symmetry are it sort of
charts the part to new and wieder
objects okay
so does that make sense that's where
we're going now for that reason you
didn't get a piece of paper just ago
okay for that reason you can see the
functions that we're starting with today
in fact all the ones on both sides of
this piece of paper they're all
functions that you know about okay and
we could graph these without knowing
about addition and subtraction of
functions but I wants to use addition
and subtraction of functions l lens okay
so here's the first one we're looking at
f of X equals 2x minus 1 and G of x
equals x plus 2 my first question to you
is which of these is which which one is
the f of X and how can you tell which
one can you describe how would you
describe without like saying oh it's
that one right what language did you use
yes
yeah that's a really good question do
the ride you're going to go ahead you
have a good okay try and use some
language right because I'm like which
one I don't know you hold on guys let's
let her every opportunity speak yeah ah
okay so the y-axis is here right so you
can see where negative one is on the
y-axis right it's right there right that
guy there okay and that's the
y-intercept of y equals 2x minus 1 isn't
it right
so therefore I'm just gonna label this
guy here another way you could say this
by the way is it so can you tell me
about the grading of this line in
relation to the other one like this is
the steeper one right it's great it is 2
as opposed to the gradient of one so
this one's steeper this one's shallower
okay so let's just label these I'm gonna
say over here this is y equals G of X
over here and this one is y equals f of
X you care with that alright now what
I'm gonna do here is I want to think
about what does y equals this sum
what happens if I add these are f of X
plus G of X what would that look like
okay now I already know and we're going
to use this to confirm that knowledge in
a minute I already know that you could
algebraically add these together you'd
get a new y equals whatever and then you
could graph that ok but what I want to
push your mind into thinking about is
what if you didn't know what like what
if you put them together algebraically I
don't know what this looks like can we
use these graphs to help us and the
answer is yes ok so here's what F and G
look like ok how can I use the graphs
you're gonna need a pen for this or
pencil Justin how can I use the graphs
to work out what the sum of these two
will look like well I'm gonna look at a
few interesting points that are gonna
help us here's the first spot so this
one here is F and this one's G do you
notice you've got some executor sets f
has an x intercept and G has an x
intercept that I'm going to use both of
those I think they're gonna be really
useful see this spot here right by the
way just looking at the graph what does
that look like what coordinate do you
think that looks like
looks like a half to me right and the
reason why I've put this into like
graphing software is so that I get
exactly a half in fact okay so that is x
equals 1/2 now I want you to look above
that and in fact draw a line up with me
right up above you've got this point
here right so these points are
vertically on top of each other right
now if what I'm saying is hey my new
function the new thing I'm gonna draw is
f plus G then at the moment I've got 0
plus some other thing what does that sum
up if you look like roughly any way on
the graph what nobody's it look like
it's between 2 & 3 let's just call it 2
and 1/2 okay to enough that looks like 2
and 1/2 to me
what's 0 plus 2 and 1/2 it's just 2 and
1/2 right so when I'm doing F plus G and
I do 0 plus something else all I get is
there's something else in this case 2
and 1/2 right so when I add these
together that spot my graph is going to
go through that spot the sum of these
two graphs will grow through that spot
right ok because I'm thinking about this
graph plus this graph that's what that's
what f of X plus G of X means it's one
graph plus the other one ok so that's
what I got from this extra tip you know
says this other x intercept over here ok
let's have a look at this room really
right so that's minus two x equals
negative two right now when you look at
the other graph the other graph is not
above it's below isn't it you can draw
go ahead draw this arrow down like so
right and that's at negative five isn't
it now again the whole way through I'm
doing this graph plus this graph right
at this particular x value I've got zero
plus negative 5
what is zero plus negative 5 it's just
negative 5 isn't it
so when I add these two spots together
this one plus this one what I get is
this one down here
okay rest leave a question
[Music]
at the moment I'm just thinking about
this visually right so the x-value here
I just wanted to whereabouts is it right
and then I could say 0 plus something is
something right
0 plus something is something whatever
that happens to be ok yeah it is
graphical right now just before we do
graphic I'm gonna put one more piece of
information here just so I can be sure
ok another point that's interesting to
me is here that point of intersection
right so at this point here both of the
graphs are equal to what what y-value do
you get you have 5 right so I'm adding
these two together so what's five plus
five is ten
so where's Ted it's up here up here
right so whatever I get when I add these
two graphs together should go through
there
do you agree are you tracking along with
me so far so what I've done is I've
looked at some particular points that
are useful that are easy to work out and
then I say well when I add these two
graphs together I should go through all
three of these points okay does that
make sense so here's what I'm gonna do I
think I've got enough information now to
draw a bless you what's going to go
through all of these yeah add one
straight line to another you're gonna
get another straight line right so let's
see if I can draw all the way through
this and I think I'm gonna get something
to do this this is gonna go through like
that like so do you see that part there
and I'm gonna do the other end as well
it's gonna look something like this
okay so do you see my red line it goes
through all three of the the crosses
that we put in are you tracking with me
so far is that okay right now what I can
do is I can check to confirm is this
gonna is this actually going to work out
for me right I'm going to use my algebra
which I already knew how to do before to
confirm whether my graph is accurate so
let's have a look think about that
you've got this right-hand side of page
right what our f of X and G of X they
are 2 X minus 1 and X plus 2 now I'm not
solving simultaneously here right I'm
actually just adding these two functions
together like so okay I'm just adding
them together so I'm just gonna collect
some like terms see this is just algebra
yeah hold on I'm adding I'm adding so
how many X's are there there are three
three X and the minus one plus two gives
me plus one now what do we know about
this graph here right what can you tell
me about it I can see the gradient it's
written in a form sorry that's a bit
messy it's written in a form so that you
can see the gradient is right there
three so it's quite steep and its
y-intercept should be one like so can
you look at our read graph and see if
that pans out
does our red graph intersect at one
bingo right if you use the ruler you
should have nailed it okay does it have
a gradient of three yeah it's really
steep in fact you can even look at any
spot there you can find a spot like say
say down over here right let's just have
a look at this section of the graph here
do you notice when you go across one
unit right how high do you go to connect
the next part three right rise over run
it's three over one it's a gradient of
three and you can actually check that
all the way along the graph does that
make sense so what we've done is we've
used a visual method to work out what
happens when you add these two together
and then we confirm that algebraically
this is a simple example we want to
start there is your break on okay so far
all right good